let you know more bismillah al
hamdulillah Salaam alaikum peace be unto
you thank you for tuning in to another
episode of the Dean show people from all
around the globe tune in to the Dean
show calm where we're trying to help you
understand Islam and Muslims we come
back we're going to bring out our next
guest and we're going to be talking
about the hadith what are the hadith how
do they play a role in the Muslims life
we'll be right back with our next guest
Nevada azine here on the Dean show love
there's only one Muhammad is His
Messenger a la la
ha there's only one but Jesus was his
messenger no I did that maybe it maybe
it's just a break the ice
assalamualaikum waalaikumsalam to the
katsu thank you for being with us just
like a lot it's a pleasure and honor to
be here thank you thank you very much
and it's a pleasure not honor to have
you on the show tell us I got apologize
I chopped your name up it's okay it's
quite commonly you know mistaken how do
you say it's Nevada zzzz okay navaid
Aziz tella you're with the el Maghreb
institute correct and you're born bred
in Montreal correct yep and you finish
from the prestigious Medina University
correct last year so we're not talking
to a car mechanic about Islam we're
talking to somebody who knows this Dean
this way of life i'd like to hope so
tell us a little bit more about yourself
while i was born in nineteen eighty one
in montreal quebec and i spent the vast
majority of my youth in montreal with
the exception of about two and a half
years which were between new york and
Pakistan and the rest of my youth was
spent in Montreal just like an average
guy and then around the age of 14 I was
actually introduced to dr. blooming
abella Phillips he had come to Montreal
and he had a very large influence on
myself and upon my family and he
actually encouraged me to pursue the
path of seeking knowledge and that is
what I started to do at the age of 14 I
started memorizing Quran at that time
and studying Islamic studies as well as
Arabic on the side and then upon
finishing college I pursued the Islamic
University of Medina where I just
finished from last year now at the age
of 14 you got many youth involved in
gangs trying to get fake IDs to get to
the nightclubs doing all sorts of things
besides surrender submission to God
alone right and you're over here
pursuing knowledge how did this happen
how this come about my parents and my
immediate family played a very big role
in that especially my mom's sister's
husband he was very practicing at that
time and he would see me all the time he
instead of letting me play bass like
okay let's go to the masjid they were
doing this or he tried actually initiate
basketball at the machine instead
so you try to combine them both and this
is what you see with the vast majority
of youth that are raised practicing that
they manage to combine their Dean with
the dunya in one way or another because
if you actually try to separate the two
then that's where problems occur but
Islam rather than just being a religion
of worship it's actually a complete way
of life and unless you accept it as a
complete way of life there's going to be
a deficiency in one player on the other
so I think that's what the biggest
problem is when people try to divide
Islam into a religious way and then you
know another way of life or what it may
be how did you come to the firm
conviction that this was indeed the way
of life of all the messengers of God
last and final mustard Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him the way of life that
was ordained by the creator of the
heavens and earth were you just going
around going along with tradition
culture what your parents were doing or
did you actually look into the other
ways how did you come to know that this
was indeed the way of life from the
creator of the heavens and earth upon
reading text from the Quran and the
Sunnah I realized that a las panel is
either took into consideration the three
aspects of men the mind to the body and
the soul and it is only a complete and
perfect religion that would be able to
do so and if it's complete and perfect
from that aspect it had to be revealed
from God and this is why I was convinced
that this was the way to go forward now
tell us the first evidence as the living
miracle is the verbatim word of God
correct I'll law in Arabic we say the
Quran correct tell us some of the
elements that make this indeed something
that if somebody looks into it they're
going to come to the same realization
that over 1.5 billion people have come
to today well there's several aspects to
the Quran you can divide in the Quran
into two aspects aspect number one is
stories of the people of the past and
aspects number two is in terms of
rulings and regulations and to even make
the first category more general that's
just concluded with information versus
that of rulings so when it comes to
information a la spina wada gives us
information about the creation of the
heavens and the earth the creation of
mankind how he came from a small clot of
blood and thus became a full human being
obviously when the time of the quran's
revelation these things want to know
what to scientists they weren't known to
the doctors so this
had to be from God himself that he
revealed this to the prophet salallahu
on your cell so you have a scientific
aspect to it as well then you have a
linguistic aspect to it if you study the
Quran you will see that the pros of the
Quran is so perfect and the grammatical
rules of the Quran are so perfect that
had it been from man himself you would
have found deficiencies or mistakes and
we look at the best authors of our times
today they can write you know hundreds
and hundreds of books but not a single
of them will be free from flaw whereas
this book that was sent to a man who is
unable to read and write the prophet
salallahu lucidum is free from
deficiency from a grammatical and from a
poetic prose point of view so that is
point to number two point number three
that there is other information in terms
of people of the past especially the
prophets and the righteous people that
it is not possible than a man who did
not know how to read or write and did
not leave Makka you know until past a
certain emotive age that you would have
been able to gather this information so
that's it had to be from revelation as
well so I think these are three key
aspects that prove the divinity of the
corral we have a lot of non-muslims
they're tuning in you said another
Arabic word you said Allah some people
might have a misconception that is some
moon god right some other crazy ideas
who is Allah linguistically if you look
at the word Allah the correct position
is that the word Allah has actually
derived from the term alila which means
that the one who was worshipped and they
often referred to Christianity Judaism
and Islam as the monotheistic religions
based upon this very fact that they have
this one entity that they call God that
they worship and in theory this is
accurate but obviously due to other
differences you we eventually see that
Islam is the only monotheistic religion
at the end of the day so Allah subhana
Madonna or Allah glorified and exalted
is he in Islam is the entity that
created all of us and sustains all of us
and grants us all of our blessings and
sustenance and likewise if he is able to
grant you all of that then by default he
grants you that which is more important
which is guidance you know that which
you need to survive in this world and in
the hereafter as well so that is what we
refer Allah so this is
the one true create tour oh definitely
no now gives us real quick because this
is very important give us some
attributes because some people would
think that the Creator is a man is the
Sun is the moon and other parts of
creation so give us the true attributes
of Allah when we talk about Allah
subhana Allah we have to keep two things
in mind one Allah is not like his
creation that Allah being the creator he
is not like his creation so when giving
and you give him attributes even we
though we may use terms that are similar
to that of humans we still need to
realize that they're in a way or in the
form that are befitting his majesty
secondly we have to realize that allah
subhan allah tala who revealed
characteristics about himself so that we
may actually know or may be able to
relate to it because imagine if you have
a god that you cannot relate anything to
you know there would be that disconnect
so Allah Subhan Allah Tala is a balance
between the two that he describes
himself as the ultimate entity that has
some similarities to man but in a way
that is befitting of his majesty so when
Allah talks about himself and this is
the the one who from the Quran that
explains everything when we talk about
Allah Allah says LASIK Emily Shay what
was semi early bus here that there's
nothing similar unto allah and allah is
the all-hearing and the all sink so a
lot of firms on one hand that there's
nothing similar to him but at the same
time Allah is affirming for himself
sight and hearing which are
characteristics of a human being so in
terms of characteristics of a las
vanuatu either you would have to affirm
several of them by default and when you
think about God you would have to know
that he is alive you'd have to know that
he is the all-knowing the all-seeing the
all-hearing and that he is able to do
all things these are things that any
common or any educate level of education
would have to accept you know you don't
have to be a great philosopher or a PhD
doctor here to accept this and in terms
of other aspects how you will a las
panel also tells us about his mercy
because you know when you think of God
as humans we commit since I we need a
god that is merciful likewise we need a
god that was that will hold us to
account therefore Allah son haseeb as
well so there are a lot of
characteristics and attributes that
we can talk about a la spinetta either
but the ultimate criterion of what it
comes down to is whatever is perfection
is a la spinetta before we get into our
main topic tell us because you said
there might be some non-muslim out there
who have has this in his head because
you said a law is able to do all things
some people think that he became a man
or had a son what you guys say about
this i would say about to this that
there is a problem in the question and
not in the answer itself that in order
why would God need to become a man why
wouldn't he he'd why would he need to
have a son this would actually be a form
of deficiency yeah and it's an
interesting story that took place by a
great scholar by the name of Albert
kidani yeah he was a linguistic scholar
and people came to him and they said you
know the Christians want to meet with
you and they want to you know have a
discussion here so he's like sure no
problem so he goes and enters the the
monastery and he greets all the priests
and he says you know how are you doing
how are your family how's your kids and
people started to uproar and they're
like you know how can you insult our
priests like that how could you insult
our Chris don't you know that they're
celibate they don't get made into her
children and then he said that if this
is a disgrace for human beings then how
about the one who created you how can
you affirm children we have an example
now so you know it's normal for men to
have kids because this is what human
beings do but Allah is different from
men there's no need for him to have kids
and there's no reason that he would come
in human form this is what
differentiates God for men the fact that
he is different this is amazing what a
beautiful analogy let's get into this
subject of hadith because we have the
miraculous living miracle the Quran save
1400 years that has been unchanged
miracle after miracle you want science
and in there the purpose of life is in
there where you're going when your diets
in there but now there's another partner
some confusion for some Muslims and also
some people who are coming to Islam they
want to know the second miracle that has
come that goes hand in hand with the
Quran is this how do you talk to us a
little bit body okay in terms of the
hadith of the prophet salallahu celeb i
think when we get into this discussion
two things
to be discussed number one is the
authority of the sunnah and its
relationship to the Quran so I guess
we'll start with that first a la spina
Watts Anna threw out of the Quran he
says well t Allahu Allahu Allah soon and
in other ayat he says wotty hola who out
the Ottawa soon what Alan Embree minkum
that obey Allah and obey the messenger
and those in authority amongst you so
Allah Subhanahu chadha in this iron
certainly sir which is I believe is a
certain number for iron number 59 he
says obey Allah and obey the messenger
and those in authority amongst you so
unless upon without over here is saying
unconditionally you have to obey Allah
and unconditionally you have to obey the
Prophet sallallahu near Salem and then
conditionally this is actually a
linguistic benefit of the ayah then
conditionally you have to be those in
authority amongst to pieces osceola well
till Rasool what Odin emblema comedians
mentioned well to you all alumni men
come in this ayah and the point of this
is that you have to obey the first to
unconditionally and the second the third
is conditionally based upon the Sharia
yes so in order for this commandment to
be relevant at all times and we know
that the Quran is a message for all
times this necessitates that the sunnah
of the prophet sallallaho new salem
would have to be preserved in one way or
another but let's put that on the side
for one point even our best who was one
of the greatest scholars of tafseer or
exodus as we call in English he narrated
that when the Prophet sallallahu ala was
selling was alive this is what it meant
to obey the Prophet Sal Allahu Allah
Misenum and after the death of the
Prophet sallallahu wasallam it meant
that we would follow his son de so this
is point to number one in terms of
authority the Quran is at the same level
as the sunnah and the Sunnah is at the
same level as the Quran and the text of
this are many at point number two in
this in terms of the relationship of the
quota on to the hadith allah subhana
allah says in another ayah in certain
nod that indeed we have revealed unto a
vicar so that you may explain to mankind
that which was revealed to them so here
are was talking about a different
revelation that was revealed to the
prophet sallallahu ala
senam so that he may explain a previous
revelation so the initial revelation is
the Quran and the second revelation that
was revealed to the prophet sallallaho
new setup was the Sunnah itself and
point number three this is further
emphasized in an ayah and certain nijem
where a la spinetta says one are Yong
Tae Kwan Yin hawa in who are in the one
who you ha that he does not speak of his
own desire of his own accord but rather
he speaks that which is revelation so
all of these I ought to put together
would leave other various I at the
indicate and prove that the Quran comes
along with the sunda and thus under in
fact is an explanation for the Quran and
this is why you'll see that allah
subhana allah speaks in various
generalities and ambiguities in the
Quran and the Sunnah there comes to
explain it and this is one of the
easiest arguments against those people
that deny the son of the Prophet
sallallahu Hani Salaam how do you learn
to pray how do you know that you have to
pray for the hot mallu the benicia all
these things are not mentioned in the
Quran you can't do it without Hardy
exactly you leave the sooner we're
dependent upon it so in terms of
authority I think the debate is pretty
much of no value where the debate
actually starts to occur is in terms of
the preservation of the sunnah and its
validity until our times today this is
where you can get a bit technical and if
you allow me I'd like to explain that as
well yeah if you don't mind can you go
into that now for someone who says okay
I know that the Quran is preserved but
now how do I know that man hasn't had
his share of putting in his own words
into these hadith excellent lucka lucka
so now we mentioned in our point number
two that allah revealed the Quran and
also he revealed the student of the park
system in order to explain to the Quran
so if the explanation is needed almost
as much as the Quran if not more then
how does it make sense logically that
only the origin would be preserved but
not its explanation because what good is
that origin without this explanation
yeah so from a logical point of view we
understand that the sunnah needed to be
preserved but now let's look at some of
the texts pertaining to that as well a
las behind watch either says that we
will preserve a vicar right yes
we revealed the liquor and we shall
preserve it so this is a promise from
Allah span owada that anything that
takes the title of a thicker or the
remembrance of allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
it shall be preserved without a doubt so
that is point number one point number
two if you look in terms of the chrono
not a chronology of the preservation of
the sooner you will see that the prophet
salallahu Hani Salaam had scribes for
the sooner just as he had scribes for
the Quran so these to the mix now one
was a sign for the writing of the Quran
and the others were prescribed for
writing another source enough deposited
them and this is authentically
established and you will see that even
in one of the narrations of sahih
al-bukhari we all know that the most
famous companion for narrating hadith
when you think of the most famous
companion who do you think of her abu
huraira bottle of autonomy he narrated
the most hadith from the prophet
salallahu yourself he has another
narration in sahih al-bukhari which says
that there is no companion that no new
more hadith than me except for abdullah
bin omar abdullah's and he said why is
that he said because he used to write
down a hadith during the time of the
prophet salallahu on yourself so this is
indication number one indication number
two ali radiyaallahu ta'ala anho he had
a school from the prophet salallahu
norsen that he had written down himself
that he had saved in a treasure chest
which is the image to had saved in the
chest which is mentioned in sahih
al-bukhari as well point number three is
when we study the chapter of the cut we
know that we derive the rulings from the
Quran and the Sunnah the primary source
for the Sunnah in terms of driving
rulings of zakat is a letter that are
murdered no hot tub wrote to
unnecessarily Allahu Tanya who was a
governor in another land so on my rights
to understand he says that this is what
the prophet salallahu alayhi salam
taught to me in terms of the dividing of
the Saket and how much is it gets to
take and I advise you with the exact
same thing and he had it written down in
Santa Anas so we can see that during the
time of the prophet salallahu never said
them a hadith were actually being
written down and the prophet salallahu
hani oh sanam had no problem with this a
lot of people will come up with a point
over here and they say we have an
authentic hadith where the prophets of
allah
hi Austin M says that I forbid you from
writing down a hadith they'll take this
general term and they say this proves
that he did not want the hadith to be
written down what we say to this that
this has to be taken in its proper
context and even haja rahimahullah one
of the great scholars of hadith who came
in the eighth century he said that one
of two things takes place over here
either this hadith was abrogated meaning
that this is in the advocacy of Islam
and it was later on abrogated because
obviously we know the Companions they
wouldn't disobey the prophet salallahu
hani selim thus they would have
destroyed their Scrolls point number two
and this actually makes more sense is
that this ruling was particular for
those scribes who are writing down the
Quran the parser seven did not want them
to record hadith so that it wouldn't be
mixed with the Quran and one would be
confused or construed with the other so
this is a refutation to that point so
this is in terms of the Companions
writing down a hadith and you'll notice
that the prophet salallahu Harlem
actually took great precaution in the
Companions narrating hadith of the
prophet salallahu janio salem as well
just to mention three brief points on
this issue the prophet sallallahu ala
salam says in one hadith may Allah
brighten the face of a man who narrates
a hadith from us just as he heard it so
here is a form of encouragement point
number two the prophet sallallahu
wasallam said that let none of you
withhold knowledge if he has asked about
anything and if he were to do so then he
would be branded from the Hellfire so
point number one is to learn the hadith
memorize it and narrate it just as you
heard here as you heard it point number
two is that if you asked about this one
of the prophets allah salaam and you
don't make it clear to the people then
know that you will be branded from the
Hellfire and then point to number three
he further emphasized this he said that
let whoever lies upon me intentionally
prepare his seat and the Hellfire so he
psychologically prepared the companions
of the prophet saw them to memorize the
hadith just as he learned them and
conveyed them diligently and to beware
of fabricating anything and this is why
they're called the most trustworthy of
nations so this is just at the level of
the companions and
sure you want to include something over
there is the meticulous nature of the
collection of the hadith knowing can you
describe the biography of the person and
what would a person have to fill as far
as qualities for that hadith to be
accepted and how many people does it
line up from a b2c to the last and final
message no problem hon peace be upon
okay in terms of a hadith to be
authentic there are five conditions that
needs to be met condition number one is
what they call it the sort of Senate
that it has to be a connected chain of
an erection from the prophet sallallahu
honey we said them to the person who is
compiling we got to know who's in
between you have to know everyone who's
in between and those people they
actually have characteristics condition
number two is what they call tamil
dubbed Talmud wept means they have to
have absolute perfect precision and
they're eating the hadith of the prophet
salallahu i am seldom point number three
is a Dalit or what that they have to be
trust with the people that not only do
the memories have to be on point but
they have to be people who are away from
sin and away from innovation yeah point
number four is a demonstrative or a lack
of contradiction or opposition between
the narrations amongst themselves and
then the fifth condition is a demo and
Latin khardaha or a lack or absence of a
what they were called a sickness or a
disease in the hadith or a weakness in
the hadith that would cause it to be
weak to give you an example of this imam
muslim rahimahullah he tries to make a
point in his sahi about a particular
hadith and this is a well-known hadith
these seven people who will be under the
shade of allah subhan allah tala on the
day that there is no shade except his
shade all of the narrations of this
hadith they say that the my men gave
charity so secretly that the left hand
will not know what the right hand gave
but imam muslim in t want to prove a
point in and so here he goes on with the
narration that the left hand will give
that which the right hand will not know
so it's the exact opposite so this type
of deficiency it is even recorded along
with sahi collections just a prove a
point that this is
in authentic narration so all these
things meticulously put together you are
studying a connected chain of people
where you know their names their
teachers names there's father's names
and everyone that they study with and
you know the level of precision of their
memory and you know how trustworthy they
were in terms of the religion an average
person our times not to be allowed to
narrate hadith due to various reasons
from them is that our memories are
nothing close to what the memories of
the people of the past were and to our
dedication to the religion it's nothing
like theirs as well just to give one
example we have the likes of imam al
bukhari rahimahullah who is narrated to
have said about himself that when he
wanted to memorize a book that had two
pages he'd have to cover one side
because it would interfere with his mind
when he would read the other side so he
would read a page once and he I'd have
to cover the other side so it wouldn't
interfere in his mind and he'd be able
to memorize a page like that and similar
stories have been married about Imam
Shafi and other great Imams as well and
in terms of their piety it's narrated
that imam al bawadi rahimahullah in the
month of Ramadan he would finish the
Quran every three nights at nighttime
insula and then during the day he would
finish the Koran once in terms of
sitting and reciting the Quran so this
is a totally different level of piety
and a totally different level of her you
know preservation and memorization of
the texts that we're talking about so
without a doubt when you apply these
very constraining rules to hadith
without a doubt you know you'd have to
have even this sense of themselves would
have to be a form of revelation from
Allah subhana Allah and order for it to
be so perfect so can you equate this
from some of the messengers in the past
we're at there at that time their time
if you were living there in the time of
Jesus peace be upon him Moses that they
were the walking instructionals they
were there walking examples of the
revelation that was given to them for
that time for instance Moses he was
teaching the people about the Torah
Jesus peace be upon him he was teaching
the people about the injeel so today we
have the last and final revelation sent
to mankind
and the messenger the last and final
messenger sent to mankind he is teaching
us to the hadith the Quran exactly I
definitely agree with that so this is
the same thing makes sense oh yes I mean
this is the job of the messenger to
explain the revelation that was revealed
to him and it would actually be unjust
and unfair that a messenger would pass
away and his message not to be preserved
as this message has been preserved
meticulously whereas opposed the
messengers before they were for that
time that people and we don't have it
today since this is the very last
message till the day of judgment it had
to be preserved meticulously whereas the
other religions they would have
abrogation and other religions would
come there after therefore it wasn't as
much of a necessity to preserve them
because and further revelation worse was
coming whereas in our situation there is
no further revelation allah subhanahu
Dada says that he was hot amana being
the seal of the prophets yes closing
comments and suggestions for those who
are looking into Islam for those who
have accepted Islam give him some
awesome good advice my advice for those
people is something which I personally
benefited from sahih al-bukhari itself
imam al bukhari rahimahullah he starts
off his collection of a hadith with the
first chapter being the beginning of
Revelation and this is what you would
think that imam al bokhari would be
talking about in this chapter but
amazingly the very first hadith he
brings is the hadith of ahmednagar
thought where he says in the Manitoban
nieto in the medical demir in manoa that
indeed actions are by intentions and
every man shall have that which he
intends so from this we derived that
imam bukhari rahim allah was setting a
standard for all the muslims that
whether you're writing a book of hadees
whether you're reading a book of Hadees
whether you're eating what you're
sleeping with your drinking try to
purify your intention as much as
possible here for your interaction
because when you purify your intention
this is when the help of a las panama
telecoms and this is how you improve
yourself that each time you do something
you have a specific intention of what
you want to achieve and what you want to
get out of it so you're actually
measuring your status in terms of where
you're going so that is point number one
point to number two the last book in
sahih al-bukhari is called kita boots or
heat or the chapter of monotheism of a
la spinetta and the hadith he ends up
with over here is condom attorney ha
fifa tourney and listen cocktail
attorney allen is an habib attorney
allotments Penelope Hamdi hispana lelani
that there are two words which are light
on the tongue yet are heavy on the
skills and our beloved to AR Rahman
meaning the most merciful and the most
compassionate and they are Subhan Allah
will become the Hispaniola Elodie and
the point that among the Holy rahimullah
is trying to do over here is that at the
end of every act of worship that you do
you thank Allah subhana Allah that
you're able to do this because it is
only by his favour and his blessing that
you are able to do it and the fact that
he chose you specifically to increase
your cell phone knowledge to do any act
of worship to do any form of good as a
blessing from Allah subhana without
himself that he needs to be thanked for
so this is what I would summarize as my
advice to all Muslims that purifying
renew your intentions and then thank a
las panel data for all the blessings he
has given you may god almighty the
crater the heavens and earth Allah
rewards you for being with us today I
mean and you as well thank you very much
and thank you everybody here for being
with us here today on the Dean show we
look forward to seeing you next week
here inshallah God willing until then I
said on lake on peace be unto you come
and see what everyone's talking about
who you find one contradiction it can't
be from God but the rational idea the
rational explanation is you do your best
give up for spring guide is why I will
never give up spending this message okay
you take that necessary step you don't
know if you're gonna live till tomorrow
so you got to find that urgency to do
the right thing right now the reality of
life usually doesn't sink in until
tragedy commas you get a few bad people
the media grabs ahold of that and spends
it the way they want to if you say that
you're not believe in Jesus you have
stepped outside of his men you cannot be
a Muslim is that ended our faith
to my brothers and sisters and all your
listeners where they over 80 years Jew
or your Christian how can we deny the
one that serve a creator the one that
gave its life he's got sustained I would
read the old and the New Testament now
read the final al Quran has been sent to
mankind that's a source of healing and
guidance revealed to Mohammad now where
is recited by one in six people across
the aisle sphere start your journey here
and if you're really Austin said you
come to the Lord Islam's the only way to
go y'all let him know Eddie is the Dean
radio show